[Music]
you have the wrong guy does he look like
he can fight come on bro
you okay
[Music]
yo what up y'all it's your boy cliff
coming at you live on the bus i actually
did take a little bit of martial arts as
a youth so i'm gonna try and grade this
fight as we're going
i should also probably mention that
my name's not technically sean
what
what is it
it's
yeah
you changed your name from shang to sean
yeah i don't i wonder i wonder how your
father found you i was 15 years old
right what is what is your name change
logic you going into hiding and your
name is michael you want to change it to
michelle that's that's not what happened
it's like hi my name is gina i'm gonna
go into hiding my new name is gina
yeah okay oh yeah you can hear me
[Music]
i'll buy you some time just keep going
[Music]
uh
[Music]
throughout my life
the ten rings gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family
you are your mother
and whether you like it or not
you are also your father
i told my men
they wouldn't be able to kill you if
they tried
glad i was right
you're just a criminal
who murders people
be careful how you speak to
i thought i could change my name
start a new life
but i could never
escape his shadow
my son
you can't run from your past
is this what you wanted
[Music]
you got this
thank you
here we go three two one extra hold on
everybody
chiang chi is at its core a marvel movie
that comes with the promise
of action and a certain promise to the
quality of the sequences that we're
about to deliver this film will take
your breath away on the big screen and
it is as big as anything that we've ever
brought to life in the mcu before
[Music]
with the bus
everything had to be perfect
that was something i've never done
before taking a bus down san francisco
hills and crashing into real cars
we are using literally every single inch
of that bus and figuring out what we can
do with it
we make a good team
some days are working harder than others
we're working with world-class stunt
teams their work ethic everything that
they're doing is like incredible to
witness i was training with the world
champion of tai chi and she was
absolutely amazing
i took two weeks to rehearse the fight
sequence it's a symbol of the
aggressiveness and anger of the
character
we're going to incorporate a lot of
different styles of martial arts tai chi
which is very very flowy another one is
wing chun which is a bit more combative
and then looking at certain regional
styles to kind of fill in this mosaic of
how this character moves
this film should stand out on its own
it's got a very magical story behind it
mixed with a lot of action
the world has no idea what they're up
for it's time for you to take your place
by my side that's not going to happen
[Music]
you